[Music]
welcome back to cbs morning's a recent
report highlights the shocking growth of
child labor around the world it shows
between 2016 and 2020 the number of
working children rose for the first time
in two decades to
160 million in africa more than one in
five children works in the west african
country of ghana deborah patter saw kids
working in the fishing industry under
very troubling conditions
the beauty of lake volta is deceptive
these are troubled waters
thousands of children are fishing here
some work in the family business many
have been sold into modern day slavery
godwin labored on this lake for five
years orphaned at ten he was entrusted
into the care of a man who promised to
send him to school i didn't know that i
was going to fish and at first
he didn't know how to swim inside the
waters they said the place is deep
yeah deep so i'm afraid to go down
if he refused he was beaten
i was afraid i was thinking i don't know
where my life would end that
so i was there and i said let me run
away
eventually he did escape saved by
wallace who works under cover and has
rescued over 150 children for an
international charity
we went out on the leg to see for
ourselves
rickety vessels filled with kids adept
at unraveling the fine mesh and when
those nets snag on submerged tree
branches they're forced to dive deep
into the murky waters to untangle them
adult work made easier by exploiting
agile bodies and tiny hands
the eldest here claims the nine-year-old
boy on this boat is his brother how come
the two brothers don't speak the same
language because i'm telling you that
something language barrier
it's a red flag
another little boy believe it or not
called freedom
freedom
where's your mom he too is from far away
and speaks a completely different
language to the others on the boat
within the space of half an hour we've
already come across full boats in which
there could be potential trafficking do
you see this often
yeah we see this often
so but
when we see that we come back to do our
underground investigation
wallace gathers intel from sources in
freedom's village weeks later he
confirms the child had been trafficked
but it was too late to rescue him he'd
been moved a tactic slave owners used to
evade arrest during this entire time we
haven't seen a single official from
either the police or the navy who is
supposed to be patrolling this water
and so
children are easy prey
why do you think there is so much
trafficking in this area due to
poverty
and poverty is all around us here
desperate extreme persistent
it's not just boys who are trafficked
these sisters were snatched near their
family home only recently rescued their
eyes tell of horrors they could not
speak out loud
warnings of trafficking abound but
they're not a deterrent as we found out
from this slave owner turned informant
how much did you pay
for a child
500
that's about 80 dollars but it's a human
life you you bought a child is that not
slavery
that's how it is he shrugs over 25 years
he's bought thousands of children what's
the worst thing you ever did as a slave
owner
forcing a kid who doesn't know how to
swim to dive to the bottom of the lake
he told us
they could go down and never come up
so many children have died here
but there is another dreadful truth to
hear
you were sold into slavery
by my father he tells us
the child slave has become the master
godwin refuses to go that route
i wanted to go to school so that
i
should have become someone i didn't want
to do fishing work he harbors no
bitterness towards his abuser
he has to be punished but i forgive him
how are you able to forgive him godwin
such a hard time
the unearned forgiveness of a boy whose
childhood was stolen on this lake
maybe this time the cycle has been
broken
for cbs mornings deborah patter
lake volta ghana
unearned forgiveness is a very good way
to describe it i can't get over hearing
that the slave owner was also trafficked
himself as a child you would think that
that would be the last thing he would
want to do to others since he knows how
horrible it is children they are the
purest form of humanity exactly we have
to protect them at all costs 160 million
in that form of slavery and you see the
resilience if you can get them out of
there
deborah pada for us powerful story there